yo yo yo I'm mo show the cat rapper I
got a bunch of cats throw the bat and
get it back hats on my lap got cats on
the mat flipping cats on my map huh
Austin IV yeah huh
so I got five cats DJ ravioli queen
sushi tallied and lover the mighty Mega
Man and black savage and the S is a
dollar sign they have a lot of cat
clothes you know pop collar stuff a
favorite colors pink so we do like a lot
of pretty and pink
photoshoots and yet it got closed closed
for days that they're fresher than me
you know I felt more drawn to stinks
because I felt like we had a connection
you know they're bald
I'm bald I don't have any hair so it
just felt just right and I wanted to
show people that hey stink so awesome
too and the reason why I adopted black
savage is because black cats are the
least to be adopted
due to stereotypes people say because of
how movie showed them their bad luck you
ever get a chance please a doctor cat
but if you really got a really big heart
adopted black cat as well don't force
the love cats choose you if you have a
great personality and you're just oozing
with love the cat will recognize that
and the cat will find you heck yeah yeah
ain't done yet at the beginning or the
cat gang pulling up on y'all mo game cat
work
hey guys do you know it's Hispanic
Heritage Month nobody you go for more
Latino content subscribe here